no
[Música]
ah
i
gracias
bueno voy a empezar hablando sobre el
destino que realmente no sé si creo en
el destino lo que si pasa es que en mi
vida ha pasado algunas cosas que son un
poco casuales voy a empezar diciendo que
nací en una familia donde mis abuelos
estuvieron únicamente mujeres algo que
me parece muy curioso parece que mi
abuelito tenía como el cartucho de la
equis dañado y tuvieron nueve hijas
rubiela marlene chela carmen edilma luz
e hilda estela e isabel para que no
crean pues que me lo estoy inventando
y parece como que el destino se había
empeñado en que empezara con un grupo de
mujeres donde solo nacían mujeres y
después terminara metido en un mundo de
hombres el día que yo nací mi mamá me
dice que solo había niños en la sala de
partos y para completar soy la única
mujer y la mayor de siete hermanos
carlos gustavo felipe camilo nicolás y
bateo
y parece que continuaba esta misma
situación en el colegio que acaba más
cerca de mi casa era un colegio de
industrial donde se enseñaba
electricidad y mecánica y entonces como
que a cada cerca de terminación ando en
un colegio de hombres una vez más y
consecuentes como si no no no parara
entonces lo siguiente que pasó es que
terminé haciendo humor político y
resultó que también era un mundo de
hombres y ahí estoy yo un poco sola y
cuento toda esta historia porque siempre
me he cuestionado muchísimo el rol de
ser mujer y de ser hombre porque a mí me
toca hacer unas cosas ya él no porque me
juzgan de una manera y porque a los
demás no
soy una dibujante ese es mi oficio y es
mi pasión lo he hecho desde siempre
desde nunca desde hacerlo me considero
que soy una sobreviviente del sistema
educativo que valora un poco más lo
científico o lo mecánico sobre las artes
y yo sobreviví a eso se dibujan dow
siempre me dediqué a una carrera que es
el diseño gráfico pero nunca he dibujado
y quiero decirles que el dibujo es la
primera manera en que los humanos se
expresan al menos eso creo por eso es
que todavía sabemos
cómo vivían los hombres en las cavernas
porque nos dibujamos y nos representamos
en eso y primero lo primero que nos
representamos es nuestro entorno y lo
segundo es a nosotros mismos este v es
mío mi autoría mi primer dibujo en el
jardín y como pueden ver ahí ahí todavía
no estaba muy claro cuál era el bando en
el que me tocaba aquí ya está muy claro
era una mujer una mujer que tenía que
tener el pelo así tener que tener aretes
amarillas pintarse con collares y ser
una princesa
y también me di cuenta que dibujado a
cuatro dedos todavía hay 14 dedos
yo sé que dibujando y hace unos cuatro
años un poco cansada de trabajar es de
mi oficio diseñadora gráfica decidí
hacer un espacio en redes sociales para
publicar mi trabajo como ilustrador con
esperanza de tener más trabajo como como
ilustradora pero bueno no pasó mucho así
que un día aprovechando que era mi
espacio y que podía hacer lo que me daba
la gana me dije a mí misma haciendo algo
en la casa y haciendo un chiste y parece
que a la gente le encantó y se llamaba
laxe el espacio y se llama laxe porque
me llamo cecilia y me dicen chechi en
fin no es que hable leche pues hablo de
mi vida de las cosas que me pasa
me di cuenta muy rápidamente que el
humor era una herramienta magnífica para
comunicar cosas un dibujo sencillo con
unas palabras terminaban explicando
cosas que pueden ser muy difíciles de
explicar y llegando un montón de
personas y quedándose en la cabeza de
estas personas en la que habla por
ejemplo de mi vida profesional las cosas
como progresando pues en este camino
hábleme mi vida financiera también y la
relación que tengo con los impuestos y
con el dinero que tengo que pagar
sobre mi crisis existenciales
cualquier día a las 10 de la mañana en
la cocina en la cocina la mesita de la
casa de la cocina obviamente sobre el
amor y todas las veces que me enamoré
para siempre
cosa que me cuesta mucho
también sobre la maternidad y aquí voy a
parar porque quiero confesar que nunca
me he pensado como una persona muy
graciosa de hecho que creo que soy más
bien como una ladrona de chistes yo veo
lo que pasa alrededor y bien robo la
ciudad de hecho eso lo hago mi hija de
verdad
me encanta sea mía
también habló sobre sobre la relación
que uno tiene con las cosas sobre el
consumo y qué bueno definitivamente esa
pila de cosas nunca me hizo más feliz
sobre bailar que creo que me gusta
incluso más que dibujar me fascina ven
de forma buena cadena
otra vez sobre la maternidad y sobre la
prim y para que soy y no ha dejado de
ser de hecho mi hija ya es adolescente y
todavía estoy deprimida aprendiendo a
vivir con una adolescente
e
y bueno pero había un tema que siempre
me llamaba mucho la atención y era este
tema de ser mujer
o lo que significa ser mujer porque
resulta que como crecí en un colegio de
hombres no me enseñaron a maquillarme
aprendí súper tarde como osea no sé cómo
a los 25 años compré mi primer
maquillaje y lo intenté pero no funcionó
y siempre fue un tema en el que se
cuestionaba mucho porque a mis amigos y
a la gente a los hombres que me rodean
no los obligaban a depilarse porque yo
sí tenía que depilar personas son cosas
básicas
y justo cuando estaba haciendo la che yo
tenía más o menos unos 35 años y he
estado en una especie de crisis con mi
propio cuerpo porque sentía que estaba
como en un momento en el que tenía que
iba a perder digamos mi belleza o lo que
sea que en este momento implicaba esa
crisis entonces empecé a dibujar y a
decir cosas para darme ánimo y me di
cuenta que dándome ánimo a mí le estaba
dando ánimo también a otras mujeres en
el mundo que estaban pensando lo mismo
que yo
y como les dije antes nosotros los
dibujos se inspiran en personas reales
estas mujeres que están ahí inspiraron
dibujos de caricaturas
'dios animados que son muy populares que
seguramente mucha gente conoce acá y
aquí me voy a detener un poco yo crecí
viendo estos personajes tal vez el único
despectivos que es un poco más viejo de
lo que es lo que me tocó y estos estos
personajes tienen algo en común son
dibujados por hombres y tienen una
visión idealizada de la figura de la
mujer aunque están inspirados en mujeres
reales sus cuerpos están exagerados
digámoslo así y me di cuenta después que
estos dibujos posteriormente inspiraban
a las personas a convertirse en ellos
así que ya no eran los dibujos
inspirados en las personas sino personas
que se inspiraban en los dibujos para
convertirse en ellos por sobre todo la
galleta
jessica de quién engañó a roger rabbit
esto me parece muy fuerte y no quiero
decir con esto que las personas no
tengan derecho a transformarse de hecho
a alguna cita del d
una película de almodóvar donde dice que
uno es más auténtico entre más se acerca
a la imagen que uno ha tenido de uno
mismo adentro y está bien que la gente
quiera cambiarse solamente que estas
figuras son desproporcionadas e
hipersexualizadas y llegar hasta allá
implica incluso poner en riesgo la salud
de muchas mujeres y muchas personas y
parece que las personas que dibujaron
estos dibujos no trataban tan mal eran
un poco más amables con las figuras
masculinas
bueno y con los caracteres también
entonces aprendimos no solamente que
teníamos que ser super curvilíneas y
voluptuosas sino que además tenemos que
ser sensuales delicadas y etcétera
me voy al mundo de los muñecos de acción
y tampoco es que nos vaya muy bien yo no
sé por qué creen que es fácil correr en
tacones o salvar el mundo
y tengo que decir también que los
hombres también tienen que verse cada
vez más musculosos al menos en el mundo
de las figuras de acción
doy las gracias que también existían
otros autores que habían representado a
las mujeres de otra manera con otros
valores y en otras circunstancias aunque
bueno casualmente todos eran niños
y la pregunta entonces era cómo se
dibujan las mujeres después de ver cómo
nos habían dibujado y cómo nos habían
dicho que tenía que hacer nuestro cuerpo
como lo hacen ahora las mujeres resulta
que gracias a la demócrata
democratización del internet hubo un
boom de mujeres que empezaron a mostrar
cómo era vivir en este cuerpo y en esta
cultura y todas ellas tienen algo en
común son más amables con sus cuerpos y
se dibujan de manera más auténtica y
diversa todas ellas tienen muestran con
humor la vida de las mujeres de otra
manera nunca tal vez nunca antes vista
porque la habíamos visto únicamente a
través de unos ojos y no quiero decir
con esto que no nos guste la sensualidad
o vernos como personas deseadas
solamente que queremos hacerlo en
nuestros términos y que no sea
únicamente la única manera en que nos
miden
no tenemos miedo para dibujar nos en
ropa parece que a todos nos encanta yo
también tengo una nieta así todas ellas
tienen una misión yo tengo la mía y
quiero invitar a que haya muchas más
mujeres dibujando y dibujando sus vidas
y no solo en el ámbito del humor gráfico
sino en todos los ámbitos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]